Hello, and welcome to this video on alphabetically sorting an array.
Now, this might not sound too exciting.
However, what it's going to give us is an opportunity to look at one of the trigger points.
So we're going to jump to example one in this case,
and you're going to see that we have a before and after panel.
And the before has a list of names which are not in alphabetical order,
and the after, if we jump into the engine, you'll see doesn't, is blank at this point.
Now, I've selected alphabetically sorting because this is something that Python is very good at.
However, it is a little bit difficult to achieve via blueprints.
So it's a nice sort of example of something very, very simple.
So for this, what we're going to use is we are going to use the blueprint
nodes, and I want you to be aware that there are three different types of blueprint
nodes that we've got in here. The first one is execute Python script.
Now, this is the one we're going to use in this case because
it allows us to create custom inputs and output pins, and we'll demonstrate that.
Otherwise, the other two that you have is the execute Python command
and the execute Python command advanced.
Now, what this will do is you can either type Python script directly into it,
but you could also put in Python file names,
and it will automatically detect those file names and run that file.
So it's good if you've got a complicated script
where getting the output might be a little bit more difficult.
OK, so let's see this in engine.
OK, so here we are in engine and we are in slide seven, example one,
and you'll see that we have a before and we have nothing on the after.
Now, we also have this sort of cog element here, and that's what I'm using.
And this is where I'm going to be doing the code from.
So what I would like to do is you should have this blueprint highlighted in your examples.
Otherwise, you can always do control B with it selected,
and it will automatically navigate to it in the control panel.
And if you select it as well, you can do control E and that will open it,
or you can right or you can double click on it in here.
So we have something that's called the EBP underscore text sorter.
It's very simple what we've got here.
So we have a connection to our before and after display.
We've got a before and after list here as variables.
So what I'm going to want to do is first thing I'm going to do is
I'm going to drag in a before list and I'm going to get that.
I'm going to drag in the after list and I'm going to set that and connect these two up.
So I'll zoom in here so you can see what we're doing.
So what you want to do is you want to get this before list
and we want to sort it for the after list.
Now I'm going to right hand click.
And as we talked about before, if I typed in Python,
you're going to see that we get a number of different options for the Python.
We get execute command.
This is the one we're going to use.
And then command, no script, script is the one we're going to use
because that has the inputs and the outputs and the two different commands.
The advanced just has more outputting options.
And we have is Python available, but we're not going to use that.
So select execute Python script, drag this down and I will connect this up here.
Now we want an input and an output pin.
So with this selected, you should see in the details panel here at the top right hand side,
we have an option for inputs and outputs.
I'm going to put a plus on both of these.
Now I'm just going to call this input and I'm just going to call the output, output.
Now I'm going to connect the before list up to the input
and I'm going to connect the output up to the output.
I'll spell the output wrong here.
Let's correct that.
Refresh node.
Now, one of the things that's interesting here is that once you have an input,
these inputs and outputs are automatically Pythonized.
This is an array, but once I connect it up, it's going to convert it to a list for Python.
So it automatically knows that in this case,
but we just have to make sure that the code reflects it.
This is going to be a relatively simple piece of code.
I'll just zoom in so we can see it.
All I want to do is I want to say output equals sorted input comma key equals str dot lower.
OK, so a straightforward sort script.
Output equals sorted input comma key equals str dot lower.
Sourcing it in another case.
Right, now I'm going to compile and save.
Now we don't have any error messages here and we shouldn't get any hopefully.
Now, as you can see, this script is connected to the construction script.
You could connect this in anywhere.
It could be connected via an exposed event so that you could grow out
or it can just be set to run at a certain time.
Now, it is worth noting that this parent class is an editor utility actor
because this isn't always going to be available in things which don't sit
within the editor utility functionality because this isn't available at runtime.
Compile, save and let's see this.
I'm going to update this and I'm just going to move it so that I fire the construction script.
Now you can see we have our sorted list into alphabetical order.
Very straightforward, but I think this is a good way of illustrating where Python
has some strengths and how we can get this stuff in and out of the code.
Thank you very much. That's the end of example one.
In the next video, we're going to jump into example two.